- Have a seat ma'am, how are you?
- I'm so good.
- I know the last time we
were texting you weren't well.
You kind of, you were, you seemed tired.
- I just crash and burn.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I don't know if
anybody else can relate
to after we got past the
shut, the shutdown, like,
oh, now we're gonna get it all in.
We're gonna get it all
and we're gonna go back and
we're gonna be even more.
- Yeah.
- And my body just went, you
are not going to do that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I just
- Oh, is your body kind
like that with that voice
and everything? You are
not going to do that.
- That's my imagination.
That was more like,
stop it you crazy lady.
- I know, mine is like, not nice.
- I know.
And by the way, Jude, I
see you over there and
I love him so much.
- Oh, Jude is so, man,
last time Jude was here,
he literally just in a break
was just messing around with the band
and he just started like jumping
on different instruments.
We were like, wait, what?
And like, crazy talented kid.
- I think, Kelly, your band is gonna,
you guys need to watch
out for job security
because Jude could play every instrument.
- He could, yeah, he's a one-man show.
[Both laughing]
Well, last time you were here you were
just getting used to
living in Nashville, right?
So how do you, how do you love it?
- I need to take stock in spanks.
[Kelly Laughing]
Um, I don't know how people live there.
- There's some great food.
- Yeah. Thank you.
- Girl, I lived there for 12 years.
- Kelly?
- Yeah.
- Okay. Hattie B's.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Hot chicken.
- Biscuit Love. Biscuits are like a crepe.
[Kelly Blows Raspberries]
I don't know what.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I've renamed, um,
you're gonna appreciate this.
- [Kelly] What?
- I sat down and put my jeans on for today
and I was like, oh.
Cause I've just come back.
The top on my jeans, like
- Oh, the muffin top.
- Yes.
- So I, I think we should do this.
- I, I mean, I've heard
of it. I don't have it.
- Oh, the muffin top. So
- Just smooth sailing
right here. But, yeah
- Yeah, well, me too.
Because I'm spanksed in.
[Kelly Laughing]
But you've gotta rewrite
the song and I think
I know what it's gonna be.
Instead of Rocky Top
- Okay.
- ♪ Muffin top, you'll always
be home sweet home to me. ♪
♪ Good old muffin top ♪
- You're playing them!
- ♪ Muffin top, Tennessee ♪
I'm like, mine gotta be taped!
- I know, it's hard. That's a hard place
because there's so many great restaurants.
I mean like top notch chefs, like from,
like TV shows that have
I, oh my God, I'm think forgetting one,
I'm gonna tell you in the break.
But it's an Indian one and it's amazing.
Actually, I shouldn't tell
you, you're gonna kill me.
- Tell me, tell me.
- But it's so good.
Anyway. I have heard though,
speaking of food, um,
you're kind of classy and trashy
so apparently you love 7-Eleven food.
- I do.
- All right.
- So is this just for
like road trip occasions
or just like any day that ends in y?
- It started out that way.
- Okay.
- And it evolved into
I'm kind of feeling like
I need a snack on the
way to Kelly Clarkson
so I'm gonna stop at 7-Eleven,
get a piece of pizza.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Their pizzas are great, y'all.
Also, their hot dogs.
They just turn 'em around.
You can get it however you want.
- I think they're known for
their Slurpee machine, right?
- I love the
- Yeah
- I love the Slurpee
- Yeah. Who doesn't?
- And I'm always mad when you
can't get the Coke to work
and always, y'all notice that?
You go walk in, the Coke's broken.
- Y'all notice that?
[Laughing]
It's like, the Southern.
- I know, totally.
But, um, yeah, you get all kinds of food,
every snack you want.
You can get a light bulb
you can get a piece of pizza, you know
[Audience Laughing]
- Light bulb?
- You get everything at 7-Eleven.
- You can. That's your bodega.
- I love it.
And they said and, it is my bodega!
People are like, what do you want?
I'm like, Coke Slurpee. They're, mmmm,
we were thinking of more
like tea and crumpets.
I'm like, no, not me.
I love it.
- Some days. Yeah, but that's good.
- Yes, exactly.
- So Kristin, you wrote a
new book, so what's it about?
- I wrote a book, um, called
I'm No Philosopher, but I Got Thoughts.
- But I Got Thoughts,
that's my favorite part.
- I know, me too.
Um, Mini-Meditations for Saints, Sinners,
and the Rest of Us.
And in the shutdown, like
so many people, I felt lost.
I didn't know what to do.
I wanted to be creative.
And my, my lit agent called and said
why don't you write another book?
I said, are you kidding?
No way.
That felt like I had a, a
book report due every second.
And I started looking
at my own journals and reading
my own journals, y'all.
And I found some tough
things, which I shared.
And also really funny things,
like my mom always said,
have the patience of Job.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I said, well, and she goes
you need to read the book.
And I read it and I said,
he bitched his head off.
[Kelly Laughing]
Job bitched his head off.
Why do I want it, anyway.
- I love that my mother was like,
be careful what you ask for.
Never ask for patience.
[Kristin Laughing]
My mother literally told me that as a kid.
She's like, cause then God will test you.
- Yeah, that's the truth.
It'll right happen.
And there was one note that I found
that I put in there and talk about.
Um, Elizabeth Edwards.
Remember her?
She was married to that
politician, John Edwards.
- Yes.
- And she says this. She
stood in the storm and when
the wind did not blow her
way, she adjusted her sails.
- I love, what's that mean to you?
To me it means pivot.
- Pivot.
- Yeah.
- Also, we always think
about, oh, the bad times.
How are we gonna pivot out of that?
- Yeah.
- And again, I think about
it with the good times too.
Like today, for example
I had five different
things I wanted to wear.
And this is just a very
surfacey thing to bring up.
- Yeah.
- But I'm excited I get to be here
and meet talent and talk to you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I was like, none
of my outfits are fitting,
you know, Nashville
- Yeah, back to the biscuits.
- Yeah. I'm like, but
you get to be here, girl.
Don't be getting all about yourself.
You get to be here.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- And just pivot. Thinking about anything,
even, even the bad stuff that none of us
wants to talk about.
Depression, falling down
and getting back up.
Give yourself a second.
Have some ice cream.
Be sad, be sad.
And then pivot and move on.
- Sit with it and then let it go.
[Audience Clapping]
Yeah. Cause while you're there.
So actually you did, I
believe it was a commercial
during the Super Bowl.
It was like for mental health.
- Yes.
- Why was this important to you?
Is this kind of, does
this coincide with this?
- It does, uh, that Super Bowl commercial
was for my home state of Oklahoma
and it was really geared
towards men who are afraid
to say I'm depressed or I can't, you know,
I can't get this thing off my back
and it's Kristin Chenoweth on his back and
I'm irritating him the whole time.
- [Kelly] Hmm.
- But it really responded
to me for, first of all
let's normalize that a
lot of people feel sad,
scared, depressed, down.
Doesn't matter what age
you are, doesn't matter
matter how much you've accomplished.
Especially in the male,
it's not cool to be.
And if
- Especially in the south
- In the south
- They don't allow men to like
- They don't do therapy, you know?
And I wanted to be a part of that.
And then, like I said,
about four months ago
I, I sort of crashed and burned
and I'd never done that
in my whole career.
- Oh really?
- I didn't know what was wrong.
- Yeah. Me, me neither.
[Kristin Laughing]
Just a few times.
- Just a few.
But with the schedule
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And piling everything on.
- Yeah.
- And I think about you too
because you do a lot of different things.
- Yeah.
- We have to, you know,
the millennials say
I need a second for myself.
And I used to laugh at it.
Now I'm saying millennials
I'm taking a page outta your book.
- Yeah. No, it is important to slow down.
I know, I did that and then
I just got busier again.
- What happened? And I
think, sure I can do that.
- I'm like a yo-yo.
- Yeah. In general.
- Right.
- I'm working on it.
- Me too.
- I, I also wanted to bring this up too
because, um, our friend Ariana Grande
she's playing you. Glinda!
- She is.
- Yeah. Glinda in Wicked the movie.
So did she call you for advice?
Like, have y'all talked?
- She didn't call me for advice.
She was really nervous.
She said, I, I wanna pay
homage to you, but I'm scared.
I don't want you.
I don't, I wanna make you proud.
I go, well you've already made me proud
so it doesn't matter.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You've - check - done that.
- That's achieved.
- Yeah, that's achieved.
Um, what I wanna encourage
you to do, Ariana
is make Glinda your Glinda.
Sure, you can tap, tip
your hat at me if you want.
But really, I just want you to do you
I don't know why I'm so emotional today
because I've known her since she was 10.
- I was gonna say, yeah.
Cause you've known her
since she was a little baby.
- Yes. And now I see the full circle
- And you know the full circle for her.
I found, I was with her when she found out
and she was crying.
- [Kristin] Yeah.
- There was a cake for, she was like,
it was like one of her biggest dreams
- Biggest dreams
- To do this.
- And she called me, she said,
- Yeah.
- I got it! I was like
- [Kelly] Yeah
- And we, we sound like dolphins.
I'm like, you did?
Oh my God.
She goes, I did, I did.
I was like, what, what, what?
I mean, it just, two dolphins talking.
But I'm so proud of her and
she calls me and she said
this is what I got to do today
and what do you think of that?
And I'm just
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm just so proud of her.
I can't wait to see her do it.
- I know it's gonna be like
an out-of-body experience
for you though.
- It is.
- Just bringing that role to life.
- I'm so, I can't wait.
- I love the original.
I'm excited to see what they're gonna do
with the character.
- Me too.
- Because they've,
they've lived for so long
so it's gonna be exciting to see.
- I know.
- And I just love that it's, it's Ariana
and, like, what you mean
to her and what it means to
it's just a really cool
thing when something
like that happens in life
and it's special And she appreciates it.
- She does.
- Yeah.
And she'll, she just said
I'm gonna be freaking out. Kristin!
I'm gonna be freaking out
the night of the premiere.
Maybe she doesn't do it with that.
- She does that little voice.
- She does. Maybe she'll do the accent
when she's like, I'm really scared.
I'm like, stop.
I'm like, stop. You're gonna be great.
Like my boyfriend's like, you two.
- Why did your voice change with her? Yes.
Well you've got season two
of the musical comedy Schmigadoon.
- [Kristin] Yes.
- So it's out now.
So what's different this
season for everybody?
[Audience Clapping]
- Well, the first season, as you know
was concentrated on the
Golden Er, Era Age musicals.
And I loved it.
We did all kinds of tipping of our hat.
Mine was a, a run-on number, uh,
from it's called Tribulation,
but it was from Music Man.
- Yeah.
- And this year it's like
sixties and seventies.
So we're talking about
some Stephen Sondheim.
We're talking about some Stephen Schwartz.
We're talking about, you
know, it's gonna be great.
And the character I play is very different
from the one I played
in the first season and
what he's done, Cinco
- That's fun for you.
- Oh, it's a dream.
- Yeah.
- And all of us feel so lucky that Cinco,
our writer, is giving
us, we're like a troupe.
- Yeah.
- But for music theater.
So for us it's a dream job.
- It kind of feels old school, how it was
like way back in the day when they don't
they have those traveling,
you know, and they'd go and
- [ Kristin] Yes.
- Put their show on everywhere.
Yeah. Yeah. That's cool.
- And so now I'm like,
what are you gonna do next?
Is it gonna be, because he
this one's called
Schmicago. Then Schmigadoon.
And I'm like, is the next one
gonna be called Schmicked?
What is it?
- Yeah. I would see that.
- I wanna see this.
- I, me too. Me too.